[Music]
Hey hello everyone thanks for being here
today
I am Matt Leonard the head of AI
learning so the school of AI that you
all heard about earlier today that is
kind of my baby and today I'm here with
salad chintala who's a a I AI researcher
at Facebook and the creator of Pi torch
so um before we get started you like to
tell us a bit about yourself sure I I'm
an AI researcher at Facebook I've been
there since 2014 and before that I was
at a startup doing music and machine
learning stuff like creating music and
transcribing music and before that I was
doing deep learning research and that's
pretty much all I have nice cool thanks
so the I'm be talking with Salman today
basically about about pi torch but also
careers in AI so at Udacity on one of
our main goals is to get people into you
know these jobs in AI and like the AI
field is exploding and so we just want
to talk with sound today about like how
students can actually you know start
getting into these AI jobs so the first
question so I just want to provide some
context around we're gonna be talking
about so AI artificial intelligence and
machine learning and deep learning are
all sort of used interchangeably but
they're actually quite different so just
wonder if you can like provide us some
context about what are the differences
between these and how do they relate
sure
okay so machine learning is what I think
is what people are doing and deep
learning was invented as a term to get
more funding from the garden
deep learning was
people's people started writing grants
for oh I'm building this neural network
and NSF wouldn't give grants if we were
like oh we're doing deep learning but
now the way people are using deep
learning is that if you use anything
that's neural network base if use
convolutional net words recurrent
networks adversarial networks any of
that that is deep learning and machine
learning is sort of referred to as you
probably are using neural networks what
you might also be using kernel methods
or Gaussian processes or something like
that so machine learning is sort of like
the broad field that covers multiple
methods and AI is sort of the entire
field of it it's just the term for for
that the broad field like it's not it's
it's even hard to define very well like
in AI we don't even know the breadth of
the field yet it's sort of that very
broad term we want to get to AI and it
covers things like expert systems that
no one does anymore and it covers a
bunch of other things that not machine
learning that's not just like you know
statistical correlations but also core
is like a broad set of other methods
that people think are essential for
intelligence right so my next question I
think I'm very similar to you and that I
started studying machine learning and
neural networks of quite a long time ago
and it was before deep learning was
actually a thing like a term like it
just didn't really exist as deep
learning at that point so I was
wondering how did you get your start and
deep learning and AI sure it was very
accidental I I was generally interested
in computer vision I saw a TED talk by
Steve sites I think from Microsoft
research he was talking about how he
took a bunch of pictures at historical
monument and
then his system at the time is called
Photosynth could automatically stitch
things in 3d and and for me I was like
how do you match like one photo to
another photo like how do you know the
correspondences and I was in my third
year of undergrad and I was curious and
so I went down that path of like just
trying to understand how these things
were built I actually wanted to go
become a visual effects artist a really
bad one because like I actually went and
interned in a visual effects company and
they sort of kicked me out and so
there's my second choice I tried to do
some computer vision research back in
India this University culture flighty
and then I went to CMU sort of fun like
a visiting program I went there spent
some time at the robotics Institute for
about six months where I was taking a
course where you learned how to play
robot soccer and I was also working with
like one other researcher at the
robotics Institute and I was applying
for a grad school at that time I didn't
get into all of my first choices and I
looked for very dude where are they
accepting applications late and they do
computer vision and I Google for that
and I saw this like a really janky web
page of young lagoons where he claimed
to be doing some object detection and I
was like okay I'll apply to NYU and I
got into NYU and I emailed Yann
back then there was 2010 he was not as
busy as he is today so he he replied
back at me and I was like oh let's meet
at this date and time and he he met me
and he asked me like do you know
anything about neural networks I'm like
no idea and he explained stuff and he
got me in touch with on his PhD students
and I started working with the PhD
student and slowly understood you know
networks back frog worked on my first co
work on my first deep learning framework
called EB learned that was like first
authored by this guy called Pierre
servin a and then I graduated from NYU
couldn't find a job in deep learning as
it exists today because there was no
jobs and in deep learning and I went on
to go to startup that Jana can
co-founded which just got funding and he
was trying to do like music generation
doing deep using deep learning on mobile
phones I did that for a couple of years
the business wasn't doing super well and
I was looking for other opportunities
and and among many in 2014 Yan said oh
I'm running this research lab now I'm
going to come in and be an engineer
that's that's the full story nice great
story and so now you're working on PI
torch which is a deep learning framework
in Python similar to like tinsel flow
and caris so I'm really curious you know
tens of flow and caris in cafe like all
these deep learning frameworks existed
when you started creating pi torch so
like what led you to creating and like
kind of what what did you see was
missing that led to pi torch
that's a good question I'll try to
answer it without hurting people's
feelings
so then so PI toured started off so at
that time when Piper started I was
maintaining a framework called torch it
was based out of Lua which is this
language that's obscure but it like
there's a big deep learning framework
cultures that that used it and it had a
curse like model and it worked pretty
well except that Lua as an ecosystem is
really small
I also torches design has existed from
like 2009-2010 and you know how as a
field as we move in terms of research
the tooling has to move with you
otherwise the tooling becomes irrelevant
it's
flexible enough for what researchers
want today so torches design was aging
and I was like I need a new tool and
tensor blow came like a year before that
and we tried it and it just wasn't
cutting it for us like we couldn't debug
day to day things and and is it was like
for us like a very personal opinion it
was painful to use so then we were like
okay why don't we just build something
that's torch based but in Python that
has an ear design from all the lessons
we learned from the last few years and
that's pretty much how it started great
yeah so as nerdy as this sounds to have
a favorite deep learning framework like
pi torch is my favorite deep learning
framework so right thank you for
creating it so then how does pi torch
like fit into kind of the the ecosystem
and workflow of like typical deep
learning models how does it fit into the
ecosystem and workflow well you use
fighters for everything III don't I
don't quite understand so so in my mind
so kind of the workflow for defining
machine learning models is you know you
kind of like identify your problem you
start collecting the data and labeling
it and then you can train and build your
model and then eventually you have to
deploy it somehow so your users can use
it right so then where yeah where's pi
torch fit I say so hydrogen Able's you
to take your data right rapid data
loaders they're a highly performant in
very few lines of Python and then write
your model definition however
complicated it is however crazy your
idea or model is and train it to
conversions and then you export it to
like some deployable format and you ship
it to production
that's where fire torches it doesn't yet
cover things like shipping to mobile
phones or shipping to like a Python list
production environment but everything
else in the deep learning workflow it
covers pretty well excellent
so then so with quite torch like
learning deep learning and AI in general
so what's your what's your actual advice
for you know for students of ours or
just you know people in general about
how to actually get into the AI feel
like I actually get these jobs get into
a how to get the jobs my answer is that
you back solve from what companies are
looking for so if you look at let's take
like two sets of two types of jobs right
one is jobs where you're sort of like a
data scientist but you're maybe like a
deep learning scientist right you
there's a lot of data lying around or
let's say you have to like set up data
collection you look at it from like a
perspective of a company who who needs
someone like this for the purpose of
either collecting data and building a
model and then integrating it into their
existing product so the skills that you
generally look for in those cases are
understanding how to build deep learning
pipelines that have not yet been built
understanding what data you need to
build a model that can train well and
how to collect such data if you have
limited data how to augment your data
well what kind of model should work well
like wouldn't work well those kind of
intuitions are the skills but people
look for and as someone who's a student
who's looking for a job like one of the
one of the challenges is how do you give
signal to people that you have those
skills right like you might have those
skills but there's a whole other part
where like you have to like tell show
people that you have those skills and I
think one effective way is to build out
some pride
of yours on github or write a blog post
or like show that you built an app and
to end that that that uses deep learning
successfully those those are the kind of
skills you would need if you wanted an
industry job very your serve like a data
scientist less deep learning scientists
if if you want to be more of like an
engineer who works in the like if you
want to work on my team for example if
you're a core engineer kind of a person
then what I look for is core competency
in computer science you understand like
threading you understand like all of
these general computer science concepts
you understand programming very well and
you just learn deep learning on a job
like I don't particularly look for like
oh you need to understand your own
networks or backdrop those are those can
be taught using you know Udacity course
you don't need to like have four years
of training for something like that so
four core jobs I think engineering is
the main focus and even all of the deep
learning aspects can be just learned on
the job so I think there's this your
perception of the AI field where you you
know you can't do any of this stuff
unless you have a PhD and which i think
is completely wrong I mean just Udacity
like the whole point of Udacity is if
we're taking people who don't have PhDs
and we're teaching them to do this stuff
right so then like on your team like do
like what's your opinion on like people
with PhDs verse like sure I think we
like in the first like when we build
fighters we had no PhDs on the team who
build fight words and it's a pretty
successful tool today so the other data
for and as of today like we have a
couple of PhDs on the team but it's not
essential by any standards that's the
first like I want to give data points to
just
oh that that that's mostly a myth and
the second thing is out of my graduating
class at NYU the new masters class there
was like three or four of us who were
into like machine learning / deep
learning we all landed just fine
in doing deep learning jobs either it's
startups or large companies I think it's
more of like whenever people look for
people to hire they look for whether
that person has the skills necessary to
do the job one way one really easy way
is to look for a PhD and say oh you
spent five years doing deep learning so
you must know like X Y & Z but if you
show those signals in any other way
that's also fine right so I've heard a
lot of so a lot of the commentary is
about like people with PhDs like coming
up academia as compared to like software
developers is that like software
developers even though maybe they don't
have that experience with deep learning
but they they know how to actually
deploy software and make products that
people use right so then what type of
people are you actually looking for on
your team are you looking for like
people who have like more deep learning
experience or more of like the
traditional software developer
engineering I look for someone who
understands one at least one side of the
two-sided problem like we're building
deep learning software right if they can
understand deep learning really well
that they can come in and add new layers
to PI torch like let's say someone
needed to add generalize like GE SP
which is like like a generalized linear
equation solver and make it back
probable okay they need to do some high
school level math and derive the
derivatives and code it up someone who
can do that who is comfortable with
calculus or someone who is really good
at core computer science there's a
really good programmer who understands
programming languages or you know like
assembly threading like Cindy that kind
of stuff I look for either one of those
aspects cool so then so after our
program so we you know we do our best to
to teach students like set them up get
them ready to you know start applying
for these AI jobs but we also try to
help them like afterwards right and so
I'm try to teach them or you know at
least like tell them what to do so they
can keep like upskilling after our
programs so what do you think are the
best ways to do this did they get a job
or not oh yeah so like in the the
process of like so job hunting before
okay so after they finished your course
but in the process of job hunting I
would say like keep yourself busy do
cattle competitions like read a research
paper and implement it build a home
gardening bot like do anything they'll
just like keep your skills sharp
definitely one of the things I would say
is the most tempting thing to do is only
read papers and not implement them or
like like it's like very easy to consume
information but not act upon it but like
you you can't really sharpen your skills
if you don't do the second part so
that's that's all I would say and then
what's the the best way to sort of stay
up to date with like everything that's
going on it changes so fast I mean like
with last last year like Pytor shouldn't
exist and now it exists and yeah yeah so
that's a question I'm I've been trying
to find an answer for I can't stay up to
date with everything that's going on one
way to see it is don't stay up to date
with every single thing going on in the
field look at one particular and narrow
path in the field and just stay up to
date and that narrow path and it's not a
bad idea because to stay up to date like
in the entire field like go after every
single project but probably takes like a
team of people yeah cool so then like
within these different feel
like are there any projects that you're
really interested in several I over the
last like I generally look for
interesting papers that come out
I like generative modeling a lot
generally like image generation video
generation text generations like I kind
of want to do fun things like oh can i
generate a story from like given a small
subplot or can i generate an image from
like a description stuff like that I
find interesting and so I try to keep up
to date in that particular subfield and
there's no specific way in which I do
that I just like because I work at a
large research lab I have bootstrap
information from like other people who
heard about paper XYZ and that's how I
do it
the other way is I guess fine reading
groups at your local university who
usually reading groups are like they
read one paper a week and like present
it and other people understand it and
it's kind of interesting to just get a
broad scope of things the other way is
like just use something like archive
sanity or there are these tools that are
popping out there like if you have
particular keywords that you're
interested in you'll get an email with
like a daily digest of what papers are
interesting in that in that particular
subfield I would say those those ideas
may be great and so you're talking about
your you're working on a big research
team right so what's what's the day to
day light for an actual AI researcher
for an AI researcher i I don't know
exactly I I'm sort of between an AI
researcher and an engineer but for a
researcher typically what I see them do
is I see them coming
read a paper to go to go to reading
meetings go to do a lot of discussion
about like how to evolve their idea do a
lot of coding it's a lot of empirical
stuff as well it also depends on like
the kind of air researcher if you're an
air researcher that's focusing on mostly
theoretical work like you want to derive
bonds for your model that are tighter
than like known theoretical bounds then
you spend your whole day either in a
room like bouncing ideas off of other
people or like with the pen and paper
driving mad if you're more of an
emphasis you're like someone who's
building better con nets for like a
particular task or something you you
build out your your software make sure
everything's ready and then like you
change the parts of the parts of the
system that that you think you have new
ideas and run them on the cluster and
then wait for the results and then the
meanwhile like like read papers catch up
on the field that stuff so then so yes
we have these like AI researchers AI
engineers building these systems other
are there any bottlenecks as far as like
like what's kind of like what's is there
anything preventing you know all these
companies everywhere building like AI
systems no money yeah yes yeah so I've
been hearing a lot about I mean I guess
like the thing is there's not enough
data it's like the data part is it's
good tough part right so then in your
experience like what's the best way to
actually kind of collect like all the
data you need cuz I mean so imagenet
which is like the big one that all the
that kind of set off deep learning is
you know tens of millions of images
right so how does like a team actually
collect and label all this data yeah so
it's every every data collection process
is creative and different it depends on
the problem it's it's very personal
to each particular problem so if you're
collecting data for say healthcare it's
a very different process like the
bottlenecks are on like convincing
people that you'll keep the data secure
that you'll make sure you're using it
for the right purposes and all of that
if you're collecting it for say academic
purposes then like your bottlenecks are
like oh like we need to get people to
label the data and make sure like their
triple labeled and like like the labels
are accurate and it's not just someone
just clicking a for everything and all
of those things and like probably
funding as well so every every different
data collection is bottlenecked in a
different way so it's the solution is
not like generalized yeah you know what
do you what do you see is like the one
skill that is most in-demand like
amongst industry and like all these
companies who are trained to you know
start building AI things it's being able
to generalize your your skill to like
the problem they have at hand so doing a
deep learning course is not enough right
like you you need to be able to apply
what you know to the real world I think
that's the skill that's that's most like
that's that's been the same skill that's
in demand for like a while but
especially in like a very high demand
feel like deep learning a lot of
companies want to hire like deep
learning engineers and they want to
build the small team that can take the
problems they have and see if deep
learning can be applied to them and the
company itself doesn't have any experts
on whether this is like correct and
possible or not so this the skill really
is like can you go into the environment
where you can work creatively by
yourself and see
if something can be applied yeah cool
so kind of like or getting near the end
of our little Q&A session so then where
do you see like deep learning and AI
going what's the future of all this one
of the big things but where they're
going is it's hard to tell but if you
see deep learning it's becoming a very
very pervasive technology like it's sort
of everywhere and every different
application you see people are like oh
yeah this system we did it this way for
the last 25 years and now we just
switched it over to like this other
method by just pumping more data and
putting a networked neural network there
that way it's sort of going into like
all kinds of places that we didn't even
think it would go into as a research
field it it's good it's like the the
biggest problems people are working on
are things like sample efficiency like
one of the big challenges is like you
need a lot of data to satisfy our deep
learning system ok why do you need a lot
of data like why can you learn but much
lesser data like humans do is it like
simply about transferring is it simply
that humans just have priors on like so
much of the world that they can transfer
their skills using very little data into
a new task there's a lot of research
going on there is it like just pure
unsupervised learning like you don't
actually have to have any labels to to
get to a really good prior system like
all this research is pretty intensely
being worked upon right yeah so I've
heard some things which I don't know if
it's necessarily true but like kind of
the research part of deep learning is a
little bit plateauing so I think maybe
like we're starting to hear
like you know people are just aren't
really moving forward as much as like
the applications part right that is that
is an accurate statement so the
applications part we like if you look at
almost every single application we've
seen it's like okay you either take a
con net or you taken LS TM and you apply
it to a very large data set using some
standard loss function and you get a
really good system that's like a tried
and tested recipe that's been that's
been used on the research side we're not
seeing like methods generalized like we
don't know what to do about unsupervised
learning or transfer learning like
whether they work effectively that like
their progress is soar but I think
that's just expected as well like you
you don't cert you don't know when
breakthroughs come and until they come
you're sort of like Oh things are going
nowhere
yeah and then what is like the one
application of deep learning that you
think like somebody should do but nobody
has yet if I knew I would go that you'd
make your own company yeah I I can't
think of anything in particular there's
a lot of like things that I feel like
there exists like there's a lot of
healthcare and deep learning that should
exist already but they're not so like I
think someone should do that but then
like if I actually go dig in I'll
probably find that they're being
bottleneck for reasons that are not
technical right so like I can't think of
a particular application that sure-shot
I know can be done but it's not being
done awesome
so that's all the time we have for today
so thanks for coming and thanks for
talking with us thank you
Thanks
you